este sábado colombia ha celebrado la
gran marcha de madresycomadres convocada
a nivel nacional unas protestas que ha
estado lideradas aquí en bogotá por las
madres de los falsos positivos como se
conocen a las muertes extrajudiciales a
manos de los militares en el marco del
conflicto armado colombiano más de 6.400
según la jurisdicción especial para la
paz ellas han sido las que han liderado
esta marcha que ha tenido un cierto
tinte feminista pero también han estado
en apoyo para mostrar apoyo a los
manifestantes y a las madres de los
bajas y más de 500 desaparecidos en el
marco de las protestas de los últimos
días de protestas más de 500 personas
han desaparecido según los datos de la
fiscalía colombiana unas cifras que
responden también a la brutalidad
policial que se ha llevado a cabo
durante las últimas jornadas de
protestas y por lo que hoy los
manifestantes han vuelto a convocar
marchas masivas aquí en bogotá como digo
las mujeres han liderado las marchas y
han sido multitudinarias había personas
de todas las edades niños
jóvenes de adultos mayores han llevado a
cabo una jornada tranquila pacífica con
cierta presencia policial pero desde la
distancia y a pesar de la lluvia los
manifestantes colombianos siguen
exigiéndole al gobierno responsabilidad
por la violencia ocurrida durante las
manifestaciones y también unas mejoras
sociales que van más allá de la reforma
tributaria fallida del exprés y del
presidente iván duque